anti-vaccine so-called expert Sherry
Tenpenny is again spreading fear and
promulgating disinformation about the
covid-19 vaccine she is now warning
everyone that is close to you is soon
going to die from the covid vaccine
not from covid from the covid vaccine
Sherry Tenpenny is now warning about a
tsunami of deaths in 2023 she says by
the end of this calendar year the Year
of the Lord 2023 every one of us will
know five maybe ten or more people who
have died from the covid vaccine Okay
let's listen to what she had to say this
is very instructive in terms of
fear-mongering and so many other things
let's listen now we're seeing the
tsunami of deaths that I've been talking
about since the beginning of 21 millions
of people are going to die you know when
Judy mikovitz came out on pandemic at
the beginning of that and by the way
that was one of the biggest nonsense
propaganda films uh pandemic and
mikovitz it's crazy to even mention it
and then
that more than 50 million people are
going to die and everybody was like whoa
and when they started interviewing me
and I and asked me what did I think
about that number I said it's way too
low oh it's going to be much more than
50 million people in America alone
and we're already starting to see it
we're not
so the tsunami of deaths is coming it's
already here and I believe that what's
happening now and is is starting to
happen now is the tsunami of regret
of the people that fell for the lies
for your friends and family members and
parents and children and all they did to
your grandchildren just could not be
told otherwise but now that people are
dying like flies I mean my business
partner has 83 close people in his life
that have died
you know most people the truth is most
people don't have 83 people in their
lives that they are close to this this
is like a separate issue but these are
obvious lies 83 yeah no it's the
beginning
and I predict that by the end of this
year every person in this room and every
person listening behind here is going to
know a minimum of five probably ten or
more close friends and family you don't
have as many friends as her business
partner so you'll have only five to ten
people die members that have died from
these shots right
so I want to remind everybody and this
is so controversial every time people
say David is Sherry 10 penny a doctor is
she not a doctor and and when I explain
it people get mad Sherry Tenpenny is not
a medical doctor she is an osteopathic
physician now whenever I make that
distinction people start writing in
including osteopaths saying David you
shouldn't act as though that is less
than being an MD I'm not saying anything
I'm just telling you she's not an MD
she's an osteopathic physician and her
claims of no scientific basis it doesn't
mean every osteopath believes the things
Sherry 10 Penny believes I'm not saying
that at all all I'm telling you is
actual medical doctors have debunked her
claims health organizations have
debunked her claims many osteopaths have
also debunked her claims but in the
sense that osteopathic Physicians are
doctors she is indeed a doctor now if
she sounds familiar and this is really
the big point I want to make it's
because we have listened to her
predictions in the past and of course
none of them have come to pass what I
would like is accountability for these
people when they make these predictions
let's remember and then we can follow up
and say hey that stuff didn't happen
because remember when she said this last
year the more shots you get the more the
more you destroy your immune system and
the faster that happens and it's
anticipated the German data says
that by the end of 2022
every fully vaccinated person over the
age of 30 may have the equivalent of
full-blown
vaccine-induced immune suppressed AIDS
ladies and gentlemen as a fully
vaccinated person over the age of 30 I
am here today to tell you I do not have
full-blown vaccine induced immune
suppressed AIDS
I do have a little neck pain from a
weird movement I did at the gym three
days ago but I don't have full-blown
AIDS so the point is it's fear fear fear
and we're going to talk about this later
I can't believe I'm saying these words
but later on in the show I'm going to
talk to you about Tucker Carlson
fear-mongering about his space vagina I
I know it sounds insane but it's what it
is
um they have to induce fear
fear generates the environment they need
in order to then sell you something
whether it's tickets to an event or a
product or liquid liquid silver whatever
it is they sell you and then there's no
follow-up and there's no accountability
we have to hold these people accountable
for their endless failed predictions
this is yet another one of those and if
you want us if you're listening today
and you want to see what this looks like
when this woman makes these claims we'll
have all of these clips on our YouTube
channel youtube.com the davidpackman
show and on our Instagram which you can
find by searching Instagram for David
Pacman show